[Musik]
hallo ihr lieben es ist nicht mehr so
weit in einer woche ist zuckerfest und
wissing habe ich heute noch eine leckere
süßspeise für euch wir machen heute ein
leckeres bisher mit katalog und nutella
so eine leckere kombination ich bin sehr
gespannt was ihr davon haltet
[Musik]
hier kommen unsere wenigen zutaten wir
benötigen 250 gramm car data systems
engel vaters findet ihr im türkischen
supermarkt außerdem 125 gramm
geschmolzene butter dann brauchen wir
noch etwas weiche butter zum einfetten
der form
außerdem noch zuckersirup ich habe euch
das letzte nati videos angezeigt
verlinkt euch aber nochmal alles in die
infobox und auch die zutaten nochmal und
gebrauchen ca 12 esslöffel nutella und
ich mache es mir ganz einfach ich nehme
mir eine küchen schere und schneidet
dann das kdf in kleine stücke
die stücke die jetzt noch zusammen
kleben am besten stimme den händen
auseinander rutschen und dann könnt ihr
schon die butter mit hinzugeben und
alles gut miteinander vermengen
[Musik]
so unser kader ist nun vorbereitet und
jetzt geht es weiter mit der masse in
form
die wird reichlich mit weicher butter
eingefettet hier bitte auch nicht zu
sparsam sein denn nur so könnte es am
ende richtig gut auf der form rausholen
[Musik]
und jetzt das kdf in die vorbereitete
form gleichmäßig eingefüllt wer übrigens
kein massen blech zur hand hat der kann
auch backofen feste tassen oder backofen
feste formen
[Musik]
ganz wichtig ist dass ihr das ganze
jetzt mit einem glas flach an drückt und
diesen schritt die auch nicht aussparen
den punkt funktioniert das ganze leider
nicht
[Musik]
im vorgeheizten backofen bei 200 grad
dürfte das ganze jetzt bei mir für 20
minuten backen auf die heißen katar ist
martins kommt jetzt der kalte
zuckersirup er kann auch laut sein das
ist auch kein problem er sollte nun
nicht heilt seien roma finn sind es ein
bis zwei esslöffel zucker sirup
nun muss das ganze zum kühlen 15 minuten
ins gefrierfach und nach der kür zeit
nehmen wir die karten sind mit einer
winkel palette heraus
am besten müsst ihr es zuerst vom rand
und hebt das ganze dann vom boden an
das hotel habe ich mir in meinen
spritzbeutel gefahren und vorne die
spitze abgeschnitten und gebe davon
jetzt ca 1 esslöffel auf jedem advent
und ich habe noch ein paar vorschläge
für euch wer kein nutella mag der kann
auch alles aufgeben oder sahne ihr könnt
auch zum beispiel kein markt gebraucht
und schmeckt auch sehr lecker
lasst eurer fantasie einfach freien lauf
[Musik]
garniert wird das ganze jetzt noch mit
schönen grünen pistazien und dann sind
unsere teller muffins auch schon fertig
falls jetzt auch lust bekommen hat die
leckeren carina fünf nachzumachen dann
schickt man doch gerne eure fotos über
instagram oder schreibt ihr feedback
gerne in die kommentare
bis zum nächsten mal auf die gis kitchen
[Musik]